there are marvel movies that are like
awesome stories that are stupidly fun to
watch and in marvel movies where it
seems like the future of everything
hinges on it and this kind of feels a
bit like the latter how much of a
turning point for the mcu would you say
this movie is i don't know
i mean you know i think i think they all
have elements now of being big step
forwards we're entering a new a new
phase so
i don't know i think that i think that
that one remains to be seen i would i
would say it definitely
fits the bill of wild entertainment and
character development and everything
else we've come to love of previous
films
um
i will say this it definitely blows the
doors of the multiverse open so that is
is certainly what it uh delivers
um
yeah you have to wait and see i i guess
i mean it's interesting like what what
my position or what strange's position
is and the
pattern of characters in this um
new
phase is interesting he's certainly
developed from someone who thinks he can
do it all on on his own to realizing
that he has to collaborate and not
always hold the knife himself
um
so that's interesting is the development
i guess within what's going on with all
the characters in the mcu but
yeah i i don't know that really i think
that's kind of for audiences to judge i
will say this it feels like an ensemble
film feels like an avengers film at
times it's pretty pretty epic
sam raimi is like the godfather of our
modern superhero movies
he's the guy and for a while it felt
like he wasn't going to come back to it
and you've been doing this with a lot of
talented directors for a while what
about sam raimi is really distinctive
about his approach to making these
movies that he
well
trademark visual styles of bringing uh
jump scares or shot kara and the kind of
horror genre that he defined at a
certain era into
the um
comic book superhero genre which he also
redefined 20 years ago with kevin feige
as his able assistant who is now his
able um
ceo of uh of the studio
uh and her producer on this so it's a
long old journey for some and i think
you know he's just been talking about
it's interesting to hear some of the
season is him saying you know what's the
difference for you and him talking about
how
actually maybe i shouldn't talk about it
too much because you're probably going
to interview him as well aren't you so
i'll let him answer that but it was
fascinating listening to him talk about
how tech and the ability to communicate
instantly means that decisions can be
made on the spot and they really had to
we were working in conjunction with
three other films or three other
entities of this continuing story uh
this this serial of all serials that is
the mcu so there was a lot of things
that had to change and juggle and remain
uncertain or informed sometimes until we
were committing them to tape on the day
so
yeah an interesting evolution in the art
form of making these kind of films and
yet at the center of it all i wouldn't
say this is any different from other
directors i've worked with who are good
directors um but it's a trait of good
directors that he has in space he's he's
egoless
you really want to please him he's a
great first audience
um you know he's it's really is a good
moment when you get him going and when
you make him laugh and i had as much fun
doing that with scott so it doesn't mark
him out i suppose but
and you know for some of the guests this
season an iconic he's super humble he's
incredibly collaborative and the first
to acknowledge that he just draws on
everything around him like we all do
really i certainly do to do what we do
individually that's awesome well thank
you so much for the time sir uh very
very excited for this one it was brief
but i loved it
you